je suis à Taipei au grand marché en
plein air de la rue Diwa pour vous faire
vivre les festivités du Nouvel an
lunaire c'est incroyable il y a du monde
de vues dans tous les sens partout
partout partout partout partout partout
ah bah oui c'est certain qu'on veut le
gingembre le nouvel an lunaire qu'on
appelle aussi le nouvel an chinois ou la
fête du printemps c'est une vieille fête
qui remonte à il y a plus de 3500 ans
même si la Chine et les autres pays en
Asie utilisent désormais le calendrier
grégorien les fêtes sont encore basées
sur le cycle de la lune donc le Nouvel
An arrive cette année en 2023 le 22
janvier pour les fêtes du Nouvel an
lunaire on porte le rouge et la couleur
or pour apporter prospérité bonheur et
chance tofu puant spécialité de Taïwan
et comment souhaitons bonne année en
mandarin